one of the things that we are
discovering about people who are active
in philanthropy is how that philanthropy
turns on interesting things like gender
like region like religious background
were you did you ever attend religious
school I did not but I grew up in a very
religious you know Catholic family with
very devout parents not extreme in any
way but very you know very steadily
devout went to church every Sunday and
it's interesting that you mentioned that
because one of the causes I support came
out of my church experience Covenant
House so coveted do you guys know coming
in house the original founder of
Covenant House came to my church when I
was 13 years old and was the guest
person to give a sermon and talked about
covenant house which is at the time was
just in New York which is a place where
runaway children could come and be taken
in and sometimes reconnect with their
families and sometimes not but taken in
and cared for and closed and now they do
job training and all kinds of things and
they're in many cities and I was 13
years old this made such an impression
of me I started giving money when I was
13 to this cause and that is one of the
ones that I have kept as a defined cause
that I you know I try to support in some
significant way so I don't know how that
ties in I mean obviously there was a
there was a religious component to that
there was a you know a feeling of
helping people less fortunate than
myself and understanding that that was
part of what I was supposed to do but it
was even now I can almost remember the
sort of emotional connection that made
me say that's you know I want to do
something about that no covenant house I
use it by way of explaining how you've
stayed connected now covenant house is
how to rocky road for a little bit yes
as Yale has had an any any organization
goes through how did you and why did you
stay with them or stay with Yale or any
through the hard times why do you do
that well because I think in that
particular instance
the mission of the organization and the
work of the organization was clear the
mission was clear and important and the
work of the ordination was going to go
on in spite of the difficulties that
they had with the leadership they were
going to get the right new leaders and
they did in fact get the right new
leaders to continue this mission I
suppose if i were there in the inside
the walls of that organization at the
time i might have wondered whether it
was going to survive but as an outsider
i thought it's almost more important for
me to continue to support them because
they probably will have less support
because you know the things that go on
and and with with yale as well with yale
i actually don't see I haven't been so
involved in a time when I thought there
was a problem you know there have been
lots of issues that have come out it you
know publicly about things that Yale
gets criticized for but I've been in a
way on the inside you know I know the
administration and I can see what's
going on and how they react as people to
some of the things that go on and I see
the good faith and what I feel is a real
commitment to the right values so
probably part of the effect of my being
able to be involved at this level and
give this time in talent is that I also
am able to see the you know it's almost
like politics right you see that you can
spend enough time to figure out what's
really going on and examine the nuances
and not react to a superficiality about
a situation but I so I think it's
important really in both cases focusing
on what's really happening and what the
mission is and what you want to help
them accomplish